make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with the conclusion
of world's funnest yes we are we are
wrapping up the world's funnest event
this is fun right I mean well I guess it
should be right world's funnest it
should be fun
you would hope it would be fun ah this
is the end of the whole thing so in the
last video that we did we basically had
this kind of cat-and-mouse game right
where bat-mite was trying to get away
from Mixel pedelec missile pedelec was
chasing after him and they kept hopping
and skipping through these different
universes now so far we've only really
seen the 5th dimension in the real world
and the world of anthropomorphic animals
right captain carrot captain care I love
captain carrot captain carrots super
bunny
I love captain carrots so much I don't
know why he's just like my favorite
character and all of DC Comics I love
the fact that he's just a super buddy
this time around that might of course
teleports away just like he always had
been
but when Mixel pedelec finally locates
him it's on the planet of apocalypse and
mitchell pedelec has no idea what this
is right and it's kind of interesting to
see that mitchell pedelec doesn't know
who darkside is he's never heard of the
planet of apocalypse or anything like
that now keep in mind this is a kind of
an else world story the main DC Universe
mix of piddling probably knows who dark
side is right amis aware of dark sides
existence off the top of my head I don't
really know of any stories where the two
crossed over uh but but we kind of have
to believe that he does right that he
has to be aware of this guy and so of
course dark sides making this kind of
grandiose speech to all of his followers
now those you guys reading this dark
side does seem a little bit out of
character and the reason why is because
this story is kind of designed to sort
of mimic 1960s 1970s maybe even a little
bit of 1950s comics right uh and so this
is how the characters are written back
then
right they were written and and not
really a cartoony in a silly way but
really more kind of like on the nose
right he was kind of like I am Darkseid
and today I'm going to go achieve this
thing and I'm gonna do this with the
help of my followers because I'm
Darkseid and nothing can stop me that's
kind of how they talked nowadays is
totally different like I'm Darkseid and
it's about to pop off like it's about to
get real right like that's that's kind
of how they talk now you know it's it's
far less on the nose than it used to be
which reality it kind of makes me a
little nostalgic for for those 60s 70s
comics granted it makes me nostalgic for
an era of comics that I didn't live in
right I was I was born 84 I wasn't gonna
live back then let alone able to
understand what it was that I was
reading I'm a 90s comics kid right like
I was always reading comics the 90s ah
so
all this stuff is you know 20 30 years
before my time but it is kind of a cool
thing because when mix up Italy can in
bat-mite show up where Starks lab
doesn't really know what to make of them
but considers them to be kind of foolish
right foolish and nonsensical and as we
know darkside does not suffer fools and
so he basically tries to use his Omega
effect on on mix of piddling and it
doesn't work right I just kind of liked
what's interesting and the Mitchell
pedelec intern annihilates the entirety
of of planet apocalypse and presumably
even the highfather right like the the
planet of New Genesis but because of the
fact that Darkseid can't truly be killed
at least seemingly not by Mitchell
piddling which is kind of an interesting
little thing here you'd think the
darkside could be killed imaginary axis
I think actually has a really really
good theory where he was talking about
how there's true form Darkseid which is
basically the the very embodiment of
evil itself and because evil can never
truly be killed that true form of
Darkseid Khitan not only can it never be
killed
it can never actually be defeated right
do something along those lines I don't
know what it is but the dark side ends
up being early submix so pedelec ends up
basically dropping the anti-life
equation which is basically himself plus
bat-mite equals anti life and Darkseid
just kind of laughs and then goes insane
and that's how this kind of follows
right from there we pick up with this
more cartoony looking universe where
things look a little bit silly and again
Mixel pedelec is chasing after bat-mite
and they come across the Justice League
and the initial thought is I thought we
wiped these guys out like we wiped out
all the universes that have the Justice
League
uh and it turns out that's not true
instead this is the universe of the
Superfriends
the Superfriends was a I don't know how
many of you guys ever watched the
Superfriends TV show if you ever get a
chance just go back and watch an episode
it's definitely dated it is definitely
not aged well uh and it's definitely a
reflection of the time like for example
when the characters talked nothing moved
but their mouths and it was kind of kind
of goofy to be honest right like we're
the Superfriends we're super friendly to
our friend and that's basically what the
show was like right like that's more or
less what it was you know it was like
we're happy and we do happy things you
know unless you're a bad guy and then we
treat you like a dick that's more or
less what it was but uh but mixto piddly
kind of makes this joke right like like
do you guys ever find it weird that
nothing moves but your mouths when you
talk and they're kind of like I mean we
don't we don't know what you're talking
about it's like okay well then whatever
so they wipe out the entirety of the
Superfriends right mix what peddle it
kills all the Superfriends then he kills
the Wonder Twins right now here's a
question to ask here is this really a
loss is it really a problem that the
her friends and the Wonder Twins have
been destroyed I mean I don't know I see
this as an absolute win if I'm being
honest with you it's I know it's a
terrible thing to say but I see this as
an absolute winter but again they kind
of hop and skip around these various
universes until they end up in this
place
that's pretty grisly and this is the
reason why world's funnest was so cool
is because of course Jack Kirby wasn't
really alive at the time this story was
written so there was no real way for
Jack Kirby actually drawn a story but
Frank Miller was and or Frank Miller
still is alive um and so what this does
is it basically picks up in the Dark
Knight Returns universe and like
literally they show up here with Batman
and Superman from Dark Knight Returns
and these guys are a lot more grisly
than you would normally expect but Mixel
pedelec kind of you know runs us off at
the same time now one of the things to
get here is that in the Dark Knight
Returns there was a lot of narrative
that went on that story right I've got a
lot of narration of course there were
words there was text people talking but
a good chunk of it was narration and
that's kind of what you get here you
also get Carrie Kelley which is kind of
cool ah but you basically get this comic
written as if it was written in The Dark
Knight Returns universe and that's what
we're gonna find
as we're jumping through these different
universes were basically gonna find that
these different universes are written
exactly the way they were in the comics
and Superman just kind of like okay so
like this is a little wild so he goes to
face off against Mixel pedelec gets
obliterated like that right Batman jumps
in and Batman basically gets he gets a
pie in the face for one he kind of
deserved it because Dark Knight Returns
Batman was kind of a dick and then of
course he gets hit with like a fake
boxing glove or an extended boxing glove
gets sent flying through a window and
then Mixel pedelec wipes out their
entire universe as well right and it
just kind of follows that fashion now
this next universe they go to you I'm
not really familiar with this one I'm
not really sure what this one is I don't
know if I think I want to say it's like
the DC Animated universe I feel like
that's the case I'm not a hundred
percent sure let me know down in the
comments section if any of you guys know
because I was it's kind of hard to like
search up a universe based on a picture
I guess I probably should have tweeted
it out like hey guys what universe is
this from ah but it's kind of wild here
right because bat-mite sort of showing
up here is kind of like okay all these
villains kind of seem to be the ones
running the show and ultimately he ends
up locating Batman like the conversation
is a little is a little strange because
you know Batman doesn't know who that
might is and then of course you end up
having a uh end up having Aquaman who
comes after bat-mite and then of course
you know what that might making his move
against Aquaman this draws mr. mixon
pedelec uh and of course mitchell
pedelec does the same thing that he's
been doing which is just wiping out
different you
right now at this point we jumped
forward again and we basically end up
picking up in the post-crisis universe
now this is where things get a little
weird
when I get a little wonky you know in
because of the events of Hypertime in DC
comics post crisis is cut what's kind of
considered its own universe right like
the time period you know the crisis on
Infinite Earths
time period it's kind of considered like
its own universe or at least it was
until rebirth happened and so basically
you have like all these people here who
have like you know Superman is kind of
leading the charge like we just survived
you know the the near collapse of like
every everything in existence but we're
now in a new universe right we're in
this new reality and and we can go
forward from here and we can start over
and we can make this place great right
that's why you kind of see a lot of
these characters here you see Wally West
oh and this is kind of interesting
it looks like adult Wally Weiss I'm not
100% sure because Wally West ended up
getting aged up at the end of post
Christ or at the end of crisis on
Infinite Earths odd to the point that he
became an adult as opposed to a kid
which is how you kind of went forward
with Wally West as the new flash so it
looks like it's right it looks like it's
continuity wise correct but you've also
got Power Girl kind of a funny thing
about the post-crisis landscape a lot of
people look at that crisis on Infinite
Earths and see it is like the great
reset of DC Comics now there were all
kinds of problems quite like Batman
didn't get a new origin into like two or
three years after it came out how a girl
didn't get a new origin I don't think
until the events of like Infinite Crisis
a Hawkman had all kinds of continuity
errors right like there were all kinds
of issues that plagued crisis on
Infinite Earths after it came out that's
what we got all those crises right
crisis and time Infinite Crisis Final
Crisis was to fix all these things that
came after crisis on Infinite Earths so
it was kind of weird but of course you
end up having Mitchell pedelec who shows
up here faces off against these guys
Superman is just kind of like I don't
have no idea what's going on here right
but like we're gonna destroy you you
know and then and the mix-up it looks
like no you're not
and he basically manifests a giant
kryptonite tombstone and throws it on
Superman and Superman is like Great
Scott kryptonite a kryptonite tombstone
with my name on it and that's how
Superman dies the rest of the of the of
what passes for the Justice League more
or less other crisis on the vendor's
team they all jump in and they all get
eradicated too right they all get
totally destroyed and that leads to like
their whole universe being wiped out and
again they just kind of hop skip and
jump through these different realities
until we pick up with cut with what's
probably my absolute favorite universe
we pick up with Kingdom Come and its
kind
crazy to see alex ross basically drawing
a portion of you know world's funnest I
will say I think the way that Alex Ross
drew Mixel pedelec was amazing but
absolutely loved it and I love the way
that he drew bat-mite but I love the way
that these two characters are designed
because they look exactly the way we
would expect him to write in the real
world and it makes sense right Alex
Ross's uh his art style is
photorealistic those are guys who ever
curious about that he makes
photorealistic
art uh and so it kind of makes sense
that it would look that way but
literally all these you know Kingdom
Come superheroes kind of come jumping in
and and all of them are destroyed by you
know Mixel pedelec right he's just kinda
like enough is enough right they all get
wiped out the whole universe gets
totally obliterated and it's back to
Mixel pedelec and it's back to that
night and so what you end up having are
these two guys of course you know facing
off against each other and and there
really isn't anything else to like
everything's been wiped out right all of
existence has been totally destroyed the
only thing in possession that bat-mite
has from what used to effectively be the
omniverse more or less is just the
helmet of Jay Garrick right that's all
that's that's all he has everything
across the omniverse has been totally
destroyed there's no fifth dimension
there's no alternate realities there's
no parallel dimensions no you know wonky
future dystopian timelines there's
nothing right there's absolutely nothing
presumably like the source and the
source wall and the presence and like
all of them have all been destroyed
right and that that's why this story is
usually referenced as being Mixel
pedelec at is most powerful because by
the time you get to this point
everything that could conceivably exist
in all of existence has been destroyed
right so like assuming this is the
entirety of the omniverse that means
everything in Marvel Comics right so
like the one above all and right now the
one below although he didn't exist at
the time this story was written you know
every character every every single
superhero that exists out there has all
been totally destroyed by Mixel pedelec
and and you know presumably because of
that might as well and so literally
these are these are the two most
powerful beings in all of creation the
only individuals that could stop these
guys would be somebody more powerful
from the fifth dimension that doesn't
seem possible because the entire fifth
dimension was destroyed and so if
somebody like that exists out there they
would have stopped mixed up hitting or
they would have survived the destruction
of their of their entire dimension right
so as it stands right now at least
according to DC Comics at the time this
story was written Mixel pedelec and
bat-mite are the two single most
powerful beings in the entirety of DC
Comics there is no one out there more
powerful than them now of course you end
up having Mitchell pedelec basically
a kind of bomb at a TED bat-mite who
uses the helmet of Jay Garrick to
basically block it to kind of send it
back to mixed-up pedelec and then like
the two of them like mix up Hitler just
kind of starts laughing and and that
might ends up laughing along with him
and what we enough finding out if this
is just a game they're playing right
it's just part of their thing like it's
just it's what they do right it's just
their version of having fun playing this
cat-and-mouse game where they chase
after each other they destroy the
entirety of the omniverse of all things
in existence it's just their way of
having a good time and of course they
reset everything back to normal
right that's the power that they have
that's why I say mix of pedelec is so
ridiculously opie right it's just having
fun goofing off and just resetting
everything back to normal once they're
done there's nothing these guys cannot
do like they are omnipotent in the most
extreme degree like by they they are the
very definition of that work right
omnipotent omniscient the whole nine
yards nothing can get past them and so
if they kind of make this deal they're
like okay so like same time next week
and it's like yeah let's do this again
next week and of course that's where the
story ends but like it's it's cool right
it's fun to have these guys who are just
enjoying a rousing game of like
destroying the multiverse right you know
just kind of chasing after each other
now we don't know if it happens the same
way every week or if it's just something
different right you know of course their
goal is to kind of be in competition to
give a hard time to Batman and Superman
and this kind of just seems like an
instance war just sort of got a little
out of control but it was nothing they
couldn't fix right so it wasn't that big
of a deal it's kind of crazy and it's
kind of cool and I I really dig it
and a lot of steam I would read a line
of comics that follow the the goofy
exploits of Mixel pedelec in that night
right I would read that comic pretty
consistently can I think it would be
amazing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the rock or if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop all like that we'll catch you
all later
Bruce